how's it going man my name is proud of
ha welcome back to more condemned holy
[ __ ] I finally got my headphones working
we've made a little jump I'd say we lost
maybe two minutes I got boobies
yeah bogeys back back again you really
didn't miss anything
ah you don't throw a cradle or a crutch
so I'm like a true and we're inside this
mental hospital I know you all right we
have to click this all right bring it
down what what ah [ __ ]
get off my screen oh he moves like the
slender dude hey what am I saying
right here dudes reminds me a lot of cry
fear it's spreading oh my god I can do
like Theresa as soon as you can't go in
in what is going on I can't [ __ ] hear
them this is kind of creeping Pierce out
don't [ __ ] with my face right now I'll
be really happy if you don't huh Jew I
knew it
what are you doing in here I'm a cradle
I fight for the handicaps
all right Hoch attack
you hook a tag will push an enemy back
reducing his ability to quickly counter
performing alright let's do it ah
Reading Club hook a tag bit to your
cradle attack cradle right leg down
right now all right Trey don't [ __ ] oh
oh don't block nipple [ __ ] your nipple
mm I twice that's how I roll Oh get him
boot haha guys right I miss you but I
wish you'd kept at it
Richard rabies battle no this is embrace
gets even better I think we're done in
here fight pretty pie is a handicaps
elevator this is how I am the game sound
is a lot [ __ ] louder for me at this
time I don't appreciate it before you
you black son of a [ __ ] alright we're
fine we're fine we're fine we're fine
we're fine we're I am handicapped man
I'm the handicapped man don't play games
with me don't play games with men do you
want to dance oh I know fun start I know
the triangle I know your mama's net but
I know you before you were born I might
go to handicaps that's why I built a
panic about her panic it's your baby's
bottom here right now [ __ ] up you get
for scaring me you piss a block it
handicap or what you want what you want
hop hop
there you go get your [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] that's how I roll
that's how I get all the ladies that's
how I roll that's how I get your little
ah come here
we're fighting inside that flash right
way don't disturb you bad where's my ah
I guess I got a brofist them to death
now it really sucks without weapons
that's something I realized what is this
I can scratch your back for you petty
that's okay uh I'll call you Kenny Kenny
get him
let's get him hoodie ask radish face out
that's got your ball ah you throw that
right in my face
why would you do that son of a [ __ ] you
don't know stick that me write that buck
oh no no whoa whoa I [ __ ] you wanna sign
up up up go I never tried are you
[ __ ] bait no that's got your face huh
right
mm I got my role that's how I get to the
ladies that time I roll that's how I get
to the lady
that's how I roll it's how I get on the
lady that's how I roll
all right look not why did he go away
Kenny come back here man and I am sorry
I pepper da
it's okay Kenny wha Chaka Chaka shut up
[ __ ] ah ah ah what in what are you doing
now good what's happening I don't want
to go there Petey I don't want to go
there either Kenny what about me boot I
don't know I don't know but we should
just break I don't know what we should
there all right let's go down I guess
but penny I'm scared I'm scared too
Kenny we got a fight on I shed it's
locked I gotta climb through don't wait
Kenny don't throw young
I'm sorry pity I'm scared Kenny you
can't just let go like that alright here
we go
climb through I don't like this
I just don't like this what the [ __ ] is
that
ha ha that's Dyke okay
that's Carl that's assassin oh hey
though okay okay all right
as as their month it's mud from the jaw
ah it's on them
ah okay never dry [ __ ] yeah
is buck yeah I'm back yeah what the [ __ ]
are those things
the [ __ ] was that Kenny thank you hey
Malcolm Malcolm what is happening I
don't like them no sir I do not like
them I don't like them that much I don't
like them at all
I pity don't worry I'm with you
I'm Peter pity I Boonton Kenny let's do
it all right cut
super call super duper car run fight
look getting beer damn giant oh yeah
mm ha Wow [ __ ] so many no don't tell me
I died I died didn't I
[ __ ] it's difficult Kenny [ __ ] left
me son of a [ __ ] hard sigh click so
hard when I figured all right shut up
now kenick stop stop this needs to stop
payday I don't love you what the hell
where do I love you what okay good yeah
let's not respond to him all right here
we go
there we go that's a cat I just got try
our town bitching around town greater
try out town you stay with me now Kenny
I appeared I'm sorry about before that's
okay just stay with me all right let's
try hard time come at me bro
whoa with the bullwhip
hook up my your mama [ __ ] ad are you
stop that's how I roll ah [ __ ] there's
so many there's so many so many it's
like a million of them where are they
huh stop it
stop walking like that scam Kenny yeah
dude pity
well done Kenny well done alright no
more no more no more
don't [ __ ] with me right now don't you
dare [ __ ] with me right now
this light is such a piece of [ __ ] like
shut up game okay double that's how I
roll anyone else
again again
stop stop stop this is not funny Oh son
[ __ ] up okay [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] up follow me
oh I get it
it's those things I come on come on come
on I'm gonna end it here bros I'm sorry
I'll need I need a practice or some [ __ ]
like that but yeah like a favor just
enjoyed subscribe convert today and I'll
see you next episode or whatever I make
say a camera I know you will
welcome to vena be home I jump over
thank you fine it's fine
you I hate you